[Music]
hi I'm welcome to episode number 161 of
the weekly Google cloud platform podcast
I am a commando and this time I am
joined by Italy wonderful
ahem early how you doing Atta hi mark
it's kind of cool to be in the host seat
you get to see the other side of things
so before we get stuck in today we
talked about a lot of cool stuff about
go cloud functions we've got a question
of the week talking about running
containers on GCP but before we get like
stuck into all of that you want to tell
people a little bit about yourself since
it's your first time in the host seat so
I'm awesome I am one of the developer
advocates on our cloud platform team and
I'm based out of Seattle it is wonderful
and beautiful and green all the time and
kind of my passion on Google cloud last
two and a half ish years has been
figuring out the best ways to reach out
to all of those wonderful language
communities that we support making sure
that we're showing up as respectful and
contributing members of the different
languages that we use supporting the
language community to grow and feel
welcome in our platform and a lot of
that's just been working on making sure
that our products are idiomatic that
they solve the problems that people have
and that we're out there helping out and
just being good citizens that
something's really important to me and
I'm really lucky to work here because I
get to do this all day every day that's
nice nice awesome well as per always
with the podcast we start with our cool
things of the week I believe you have a
cool thing of the week OSHA yeah so the
honor of my first time in the hosts seat
I have the world's worst joke there is
an actually cool thing of the week I saw
on Twitter last night that apparently
the paint is peeling off of our Iowa
data center because it is so cold with
the polar vortex right now so that is
the actually cool thing of the week all
of our listeners who are currently
affected by freezing cold temperatures
please stay warm yes yes definitely stay
warm that's good for peace that is a
cool thing of the week it's a very cool
thing very cool thing of the week okay
awesome so actually as of I think today
which is today we're recording about the
day you're listening cloud firestore has
gone generally available which is really
really cool so if you're not familiar
with cloud firestore it's our server
list no see cool document database it's
fully managed for you highly scalable
and we're making it available in 10
locations as well at GA so
Hong Kong mu by Tokyo Sydney Los Angeles
both Virginia South Carolina South Pole
Oh London something else I can't read a
couple more locations are coming up soon
too as well so pretty exciting that it's
going to be available everywhere and you
can take advantage of it and now it's
like generally available so it's it's
ready for use we have links to the show
notes for the announced on blog post so
you can check out more stuff about it in
there also other stuff from my cool
things of the week list is that the site
reliability workbook is now available in
HTML there'll be a link in the show
notes and this is a successor to the
original SRA book but this covers a lot
of the stuff that people struggle with
it helps you know you start to think
about how to implement the practices of
site reliability at your organization
and one of the things I've loved about
the last year or so is that I've gotten
to spend some time just having lunch
with Sarris at Google and learning about
how they approach problems and it's
honestly made me a better person in
general things like blameless
post-mortems setting clear expectations
those are just fantastic human agiels in
addition to being great skills for
running an organization and keeping your
websites up so i recommend folks check
it out there's a lot to learn they're
fantastic I like anything that has the
word games in it there's a wonderful
article that's come out on the Google
cloud blog called building a service
online game cloud hero on Google cloud
platform this is a in event sort of
potti game for everyone who's sitting in
a room basically to test your knowledge
of Google cloud through the use of timed
challenges to date over a thousand
people have played it so in the article
they actually go through how it was
built
using angular cloud firestore cloud
functions and all the bits and pieces
and how it was put together so if you're
interested in how that was put together
and you think all that might apply to
some of the things I'm building you
should check out the blog post which
will have in the show notes and my last
thing is that I read a really great
medium article this morning about
chronic illness in tak called the tech
industry is failing people with
disabilities and chronic illnesses and
this is something we don't get to talk
about a lot and doesn't come up in a lot
of the inclusion discussions that are
going on we tend to focus on racial and
gender diversity but this is super
important stuff and I learned a lot from
reading this post so folks have the time
I recommend you check it out
just expand your knowledge of what
inclusion needs to look like for us to
have all the smartest people working on
tech problems yeah nice nice nice well
fantastic thanks for sharing that Ezra
why don't we go talk to Stuart and
Tyler and talk to them all about go
cloud functions sounds awesome I can't
wait to learn it today I am as always
very excited to have some new friends on
the podcast we have Stewart Riesling and
Tyler by Pollak do I get that even
vaguely right yeah it's pretty good
coming here to talk to us about cloud
functions but very specifically go cloud
functions so thank you very much for
joining us how you doing today Tyler
thank you for having me doing very well
excellent
and how you doing sue it yes yes doing
real good excellent excellent excellent
well thank you so much for joining us on
the podcast and talking to us about go
and grow club functions before we get
stuck into things why don't you tell us
a little bit about yourselves and what
do you do at Google and all that good
stuff Stuart why didn't you go first
hey I'm Stuart I'm the product manager
for cloud functions I work a lot on
bringing new languages to the product
new features working with customers
understanding their needs anything cloud
functions pretty much runs through me on
the product side Tyler and I am a
developer programs engineer which is
part of developer relations and my goal
is to make it as easy as possible to run
go Google cloud platform those folks who
aren't familiar with code functions as
cloud functions have either of you had a
chance to use cloud functions I have I
write very bad JavaScript I'm nice I was
after noon trying to transfer a
distributed computing talkative for a
couple years ago called functions it was
amazing so it sounds like some people
have started to get used to the idea of
cloud functions but just for those who
haven't really had a chance at cloud
functions is one of our server lists
compute products from Google now
serverless what does that mean that
means that you give us your code and we
run it for you you don't have to think
about infrastructure it scales
automatically you only pay for what you
use and what we really focus on is
having a very idiomatic developer
experience so making sure that if you're
a go developer it looks it feels it
smells like go it's something that's
familiar to you and so the idea with
cloud functions is you give us that
little bit of code it runs in response
to an event and we handle all the hard
stuff for you one way I like to explain
it
is kind of in the spectrum of ways you
can run your code is you come up with
some application you're running it on
your laptop and you say hey look at this
this is so cool then you say alright
maybe I'm gonna put the server and I'm
going to stick that in the closet and
I'm gonna keep the power on and the air
in the air-conditioning on and then one
stack that's a little bit too cumbersome
maybe you put a VM on some on premise or
maybe some cloud provider and that gets
too cumbersome so then you have some
automatically scaling application
service say Google's App Engine and if
that's a little bit overweight for what
you are working on then functions can be
the next step where instead of writing
an entire application for what you need
to do maybe it's just a single function
that resizes images or does some small
concrete task that doesn't require an
entire application to be running some
way so that's not super cool like the
image resizing example can you give us
some other examples of stuff that does
really well on called functions sure
I've got some examples of use cases of
things that we've seen and all of these
are kind of fall within the bucket of
event-driven computing so something
happens you want something else to
happen in response a sort of
programmable computing layer when an
event happens so for example imagine you
have a cron job right now that's running
on your machine and it runs you know
once a day well does it really make
sense for that machine to be the thing
where your code lives and if that
machine goes down you have to maintain
it and figure out what's happening so in
one example use cases you have a product
like cloud scheduler cloud scheduler
sends an event to cloud functions on a
schedule every day for example and then
you run code it might be something that
goes and looks through your database and
cleans up stale files it might be
something that does a data
transformation on a regular schedule
so that's one example another very
common use case I see is gluing together
either different clouds or even within
Google cloud different services so you
might have events coming off of a
message bus using pub/sub for example
and you want to move that data from
that message busts into a more
persistent data store so a cloud
function is a very easy way to say okay
I get that message maybe I do a very
small transformation on it and now I
load it into my cloud sequel or into my
cloud fire store awesome so we are here
to talk about go cloud functions what's
special about go cloud functions other
than I mean I can write go which is kind
of cool yeah so as I mentioned earlier
one of the things that we really try to
focus on is having a very idiomatic
developer experience so that means if
you write note if you write Python if
you like go when you touch the product
and you use the product it should feel
very familiar to you and to help us
achieve that goal I actually lean very
heavily on our developer programs
engineer like Tyler because Tyler is a
go expert I know these languages
reasonably well but I really look to
someone like Tyler to bring his
expertise when we designed this product
so that as someone who's been working on
go for a long time it should feel very
familiar Tyler you want to talk a little
bit about why we think this is special
yes so one of the important things for
me is that writing your application
should not be specific to where you are
running that code so for cloud functions
in particular for HTTP functions a go
HTTP cloud function is an HTTP handler
func so you don't need a third-party
import you don't need anything special
it's just all of the Hinda lers that
you've written in the past can be run
directly on cloud functions with minimal
modification just for people who aren't
completely familiar with the product yet
with cloud functions we basically
provide two ways of invoking your
function one is via an HTTP web hook
that's the classic use case we give you
HTTP signature we let you interact
directly with the HTTP object and so in
order to implement that we used goes
idiomatic standard HTTP handler func you
send a request to the URL that we give
you and your code runs in response to
that the other way that you can run
cloud functions is background functions
or functions that are triggered by
events emitted by Google Cloud
infrastructure so things like pubs
google cloud storage cloud fire store
and is the interface for that look
slightly different I assume it is a
little bit different so we try to make
it a little bit easier to interact with
those different event types rather than
direct HTTP and so the hope is that you
still aren't writing code that does too
much heavy lifting where you have to
parse exactly what's in every single
request and so what those look like is
it's a function it takes a standard go
context object which carries information
like request scoped values deadlines and
so on and you have one more argument
that is the event type that you care
about and so our runtime on Marshalls
what comes in as JSON into the event
type that you provide and then the
function returns an error which
indicates basically was this a success
or not and then based on that return
value you can optionally enable retry
this for your function yeah and so when
we say idiomatic a lot of people say
what does that actually mean the goal
here is that we want to minimize the
amount of new stuff that you have to
learn and the cognitive overhead when
you're developing something we want to
make it super easy and super quick as a
go developer for you to be able to write
a function not learn anything new deploy
it and start seeing events come in
immediately so I'm guessing that also
translates to like local development
experience if it's just a standard HTTP
handler I can just use standard stuff is
that right yeah exactly so the way
that's usually set up is having a
command subdirectory which is a common
pattern for go projects in general and
so you create that directory and put a
package main with HTTP server and then
listen for the functions that you care
about and run it and I think that might
provide some friction around connecting
say pub so where you're using the real
pub/sub service to run your functions
but for HTTP it works really well and
testing is also really nice one of the
other things
we support with this runtime is that go
111 introduces this concept of Godot mod
which allows you to specify your
dependencies in a go mod file
it supports go 111 s modulus
functionality and that basically brings
to the language behavior that is very
familiar to someone who's been using
node with package.json or Python with
requirements text and so basically this
allows you to just write your
dependencies in a file you don't have to
worry about vendor owing you don't have
to worry about managing the actual
source code you deploy our
infrastructure inspects that Godot mod
and it will install the dependencies and
resolve those for you in your container
so we feel that that's a very easy way
for us to show that we're incorporating
new go language features staying
up-to-date with what the community is
doing and also providing a very simple
developer experience that is new to the
language but we feel pretty good about
how that's going to find a bigger
following in the future so Google's a
lot of serverless products how exactly
is called functions different than say
App Engine when would I want to choose
one or the other
sure so there are a lot of similarities
between the two products I talked
earlier about not having to manage
infrastructure really paying for the
resources that you're using scaling up
and down to zero so if you're getting no
traffic you're not paying but there are
also some pretty key differences and the
way I like to think about it is you want
to use the right tool for the right job
so App Engine is really well-suited for
web apps you're setting up a store that
has multiple different routes and you
want to make sure that when you get a
request to a certain route you render a
certain page back to your user cloud
functions is really all about the event
based use case so you're not necessarily
setting up multiple routes you were
writing single purpose code that scales
automatically and responds to the
incoming event load and we try to make
that clear also through the feature sets
that are provided with the different
products so for example App Engine very
well integrated with custom domains you
want to put your storefront behind a
domain that's your store com cloud
functions very good integration with
events you issue one command to deploy
it gets wired up to
pub/sub and now all of a sudden you're
already getting that event stream you
don't have to handle a bunch of
additional wiring Tyler alluded to
automatic retries and that's also a
pretty big feature for us so if you're
getting events occasionally you're
handling those events and your function
might fail for whatever reason maybe you
have a flakey back-end that that
function is interacting with you want to
make sure that you have a very easy way
for you to recover from those failures
and you can potentially retry that event
cloud functions comes with retries sort
of built in as a first-class primitive
because it's important to the events use
case another advantage is that with
cloud functions these separate parts of
your applications can can scale
independently so if you have one
resource or endpoint that's being used
heavily by your users or maybe you get a
large amount of events posted on pub/sub
or files stored in cloud storage all of
those functions can run independently
from the rest of your application so if
you have resources that your app users
on App Engine you don't necessarily need
all of those to say resize an image yeah
and so I've seen customers who actually
end up doing things like deploying a
function and building all kinds of
complicated routing into it and so their
function kind of grows into this really
big thing that can do many different
things but that's actually a bit of an
anti-pattern when it comes to functions
what we really recommend is trying to
keep your code isolated to a specific
use case making sure that it does one
thing really well because that
simplicity actually comes with a lot of
benefits you know Tyler mentioned the
scaling another one is if you look at
the logs for your function you know
exactly for each execution for each
function what was happening if you're
printing stuff out to standard out as
you're going
and so that simplicity gives you a very
easy way to reason about where are my
failure points where's my scaling what's
my usage for specific tasks that
isolation I think is a very big benefit
of cloud functions that sounds great
actually speaking of App Engine and
having done a lot of work with App
Engine if I'm writing go code in App
Engine I write my code and I run
g-cloud app deploy and it bundles it all
up and it sends it up somewhere to build
it all is that experience similar to
what happens on functions like do you
build the actual thing for me or do I
have to build a binary and like ship it
somewhere yeah so we followed the same
model as for App Engine you give a
source code we run that for you you
don't really have to think about the
build step but since you're asking you
g-cloud functions deploy pass a couple
command line flags everything in your
directory gets uploaded via that CLI and
we then build that function according to
what you've given us so if you've given
us a good app mod file we're going to
install those dependencies it's all
going to be built into a container that
then runs on our infrastructure you
don't typically have to think about
these details but it's good to know if
you give us a vendor directory we're
gonna build that for you and so we
really want to handle all kinds of
different shapes and sizes of go code
that people want to give to us and we
want to make sure that you don't
actually have to think about the build
step all of that is handled for you the
two other common ways that you can
deploy functions are with one in the
cloud console so there's an editor there
which might work for very small
functions or limited changes but it does
work and it's nice for getting started
and then the other option is you can
upload a zip file so if for whatever
reason you would prefer not to deploy
from say the g-cloud command line tool
you can upload a zip file and say build
the function from there yeah and so the
UI based use case we actually see a lot
of people using that as their entry
point to the product you go to console
google.com slash functions you click
create function you click deploy it's
literally two clicks and you've got a
function running it's a great way to get
your first sort of step into the product
but once you graduate beyond that as
Tyler mentioned you can deploy with the
G cloud CLI we also have an API that you
can deploy against you can also do
integrations like the zip file upload so
one thing I love asking you I think it's
gonna be this can be fun so why would
people choose go cloud functions over
other languages cloud functions that we
support you
so that's a great question and a
question that I also have to think about
often which is like why do we even
support these new languages we already
have node can't everyone just write note
well the fact of the matter is that not
everybody wants to write node people
want to write in the language that's
most familiar to them it makes it very
easy to get started and alluding to that
earlier when I said we don't want you to
have to learn a whole bunch of new stuff
well if I tell you hey use cloud
functions before you do learn node
that's a pretty big hurdle that's
literally whatever yeah and so that's
not great I mean nodes a great language
it's got a great community around it but
we want to make sure that this is as
easy and intuitive to you as possible
the other thing that actually I think
there's that familiarity the other
pieces just as I mentioned earlier
picking the right tool for the job
different languages have different
characteristics so what we seen with go
is often you can find optimizations in
terms of speed in terms of execution
performance and so you might want to
pick the right language for the job
based on its performance characteristics
the ecosystem of packages that exists
around it the types of people that work
at your company and their familiarity
and their desire to work with that
language I was hoping for
way more flamewar stuff but that's cool
that's good too you're trying to meet
folks where they are with the problems
they have in the tools they're familiar
with and make it an easy on-ramp for
everyone I proved I think that's amazing
yeah exactly and I think the best thing
we can do then is we come to you and we
say hey you write go well you can write
go on this thing and by the way it looks
and feels like go
it's idiomatic yeah I think that's the
same principle that goes into say for
HTTP functions where it's just a handle
or funk and it's the same guiding
principle for you shouldn't need to
learn cloud functions go it's just you
know go or you let go you're learning go
or none of the above and you shouldn't
have to do something special just for
this yeah and just to throw a little
teaser out there because I know some
people aren't as interested in go as
they might be another languages we're
working on other languages well you
should expect to see more language
support in the future Google Cloud
supports a broad range of languages and
we want to conform to that so that's a
lovely segue into asking so what comes
next for go cloud functions so go 111 is
in beta right now that means we still
have Polish work to do both on the
reliability side on the performance side
faster deployment times for example is
one of the pieces of feedback we've
received we want to give better error
messages one of the nice things about
being in a service environment is that
you don't have to think about the
infrastructure that's underneath but one
of the downsides is that you can't
really just SSH into a machine and
necessarily figure out what's going on
and because you don't have that control
giving back meaningful error messages is
super important because the worst thing
is something breaks and you have no way
of figuring out what happened so for us
there's a lot of work on the Polish side
with serverless it is a bit of a black
box of what that machine is and you
don't know what's happening and you make
whatever API calls and you don't know
how long they're taking and so a good
way to debug that and a general just
development piece of advice is to use
tracing and logging in general and so
tracing as a quick primer is you can
trace the function calls and API calls
that you're making from your code and
this translation API took 150
milliseconds to compute or to respond so
it's not worth really looking into this
if my user code only added 10
milliseconds to this there isn't much
optimisation to add and there's a
library for that right yeah so there's
something called open census which is an
open source library it's mainly to
sponsor by Google and Microsoft where
you can export to whatever tracing
visualization and debugging provider
that you prefer so for Google that
stackdriver
but there are many other offerings that
do the same thing and we even have a
podcast on it episode 118 nice favorite
question I also like to ask what's the
most interesting thing you've seen so
far people build with go cloud functions
or wacky or just plain strange so
there's a very interesting company out
Europe in the farming space that I spoke
with recently and they do something
really cool where they have a bunch of
different IOT devices sitting in their
farms each with variable degrees of
high-speed internet and those are
emitting events about the state of the
farms so temperature readings humidity
and all of that data gets fed to a
message bus which feeds into pub/sub and
then triggers cloud functions that run
in response to those readings and so
cloud functions is a very useful piece
of glue there where you can take that
data put it somewhere where it's more
persistent and now you have a pretty
reliable way of seeing in one state okay
what is the state of my farm what does
everything look like and so you get
cloud functions as glue code but also
handling data and making those use cases
very easy through very simple bits of
code you know you're talking about less
than a hundred lines of code to set this
whole thing up Tyler you got anything as
well I don't think anything specific but
just commenting on pub/sub and just the
things that people can push through it
and the amount of execution that can go
through it and be triggered and scaled
automatically with Stuart said very
little code that you've actually written
it it's just really cool to see yeah
it's pretty mind-blowing when you see
the types of things people are able to
build and when you give them these
simple primitives and good integrations
things like hey everything every time
something happens to my fire store I
want to run some code in response to
that people can come up with some pretty
amazing things when you just give them
those pieces hey can I shout out some
more stuff that's coming up for go we're
working on go 112 so expect that
sometime in the near future it'll be
pretty similar to go 111 there will be
some improvements we're putting in all
this work to make sure that we are
respecting the language communities and
really supporting the language we want
to make sure that we also stay current
with the language versions so that
sounds really great if people are like
this sounds awesome
and they want to learn stuff about cloud
functions where should people go is
there some good resources that people
can take advantage of three things the
first is we had a pretty cool launch
video
for this runtime you can see it on
YouTube right now search go cloud
functions should pop right up we'll put
it in the links - it walks you through
the basic types of functions how to
deploy what the experience looks like
from G cloud it's about five minutes
long it's a great way to get started
I'd also recommend the quick starts so
go to the docs page we'll have a link to
that below that will basically walk you
through if I'm gonna go developer how do
I go from having no code to using G
cloud to deploying my first go function
and the last thing I'd shout out is if
you only have a couple of minutes the
quickest way to get started go to the
cloud console go to the functions page
click create function select the go
runtime it will give you a pre-populated
snippet of code that you can deploy
click deploy you're gonna get a URL you
can invoke it I'd say that's the easiest
way to go from nothing to actually
trying the product out having your first
experience with it in less than five
minutes fantastic well Tyler Stewart
thank you so much for joining us on the
podcast today and telling us all about
code cloud functions yeah thanks for
having us yeah thank you so thanks again
to Stuart and Tyler for joining us on
the podcast today and teaching us all
about go cloud functions there's a lot
of exciting stuff going on there awesome
so we have a question of the week as per
always and I get to ask you a question
of the week
hahaha so the question of the week is
how many ways can you run containers on
Google cloud platform I believe the
answer is four okay this is something
that I discovered a couple years ago and
I have found that most people actually
haven't figured out everyone knows about
kubernetes because kubernetes is awesome
a fair number of people know about App
Engine flexible where you can run
containers which is how you can run
languages that we don't support folia
but you know maybe you really want to
run a COBOL container or something and
if for your application so that's one
and two but what a lot of people don't
know is that you can actually run
containers straight up on Google compute
engine so you can run them either as
part of a managed instance group or you
can actually just deploy a VM based on a
container image it's really handy if you
just need to spin up a single instance
of a container and we're gonna have a
link in the show notes to more
information about this on a document
that's actually been updated relatively
recently because this is still a really
common use case that people have and if
you don't need all of the really cool
orchestration abilities and discover
abilities of kubernetes this is another
way to run containers that is absolutely
100% supported yes the other super cool
thing is the managed instance groups
support both health checking and auto
scaling this so you know you get some of
the benefits of a orchestration tool but
not all of them but it's a lot lighter
weight so it's a good choice for some
folks not for everyone so I think you
said for yes so we have anything
flexible application flexible as a
standalone VM yep and as part of a
managed instance fantastic 1-2-3 in
compute engine twice because it's
awesome
that's alright one two three four
[Music]
well what are you up to what do you been
doing that's cool and interesting are
things that people can look forward to
oh I've been on my winter hibernation
phase I don't really have any
conferences plans until Google Cloud
Next in April yeah what are you doing it
next right now nothing my actual
contribution that next this year is I'm
helping represent our developer
attendees as part of our sessions
curation process so making sure that our
story has all the stuff that everyone
who listens to this podcast wants to
learn excellent make sure rich we're
having really good stories for all of
our wonderful technical practitioners
who come join us every year for our big
party in San Francisco well that sounds
good well I'll be speaking at cloud next
as well which will be great looking
forward to that two weeks before next I
will be at a rather small conference
called Game Developers Conference just
70,000 people we fine will be doing some
cloud sessions there there'll be a
mobile dev day there'll be a cloud dev
day all sorts of good stuff we'll have a
link to that in the show notes as well
and just after all of that actually I'll
be also presenting at East Coast game
conference talking about okones and
talking about open source in general
particularly how it relates to the games
industry one thing I do want to shout
out it's really cool that I got really
excited about because I work on Oakland
A's in that project we just released our
new website if you go to organize dev
it's all pretty and stuff it uses a
theme that actually came out of Google
called dachsie so huge thanks to that
team as well so if you're looking for a
good way to do open source Doc's for
your in the next open source project
it's really really nice and takes away a
lot of the pain points of trying to
build a site that's very particular for
open source and documentation and all
that good stuff
oh yeah I started twitch streaming again
a bit - awesome yeah so cool yeah I'm
gonna try and keep that up while I'm in
Australia in a few weeks so
hey everyone can watch you you know
where people requests and make stuff
better and write code and solve problems
it's always fantastic to watch everyone
else's process and realize that I'm not
the only one who occasionally bangs my
head against the wall oh yeah I mess
things up all the time that's literally
my entire church dream sounds awesome
fantastic well thank you for joining me
on the podcast this week thank you for
letting me co-host mark this is a lot of
fun I hope to be back staring awesome
and thank you everyone to listening and
we'll see you all next week
[Music]